So by unfollowing everybody I kind of created this mental model of social media as a transactional economy
Where when somebody follows you?
You have to follow them back, or else you don't care about them, like they're not your friends.
You don't want that. [Fade out.]
I started my youtube channel in the spring of my senior year of high school
the idea was kind of just to document my
experience going to Harvard because I hadn't really seen anyone tell that story before at the time
I was really into watching Casey Neistat on YouTube & I thought it'd be really cool to just kind of start a daily vlog
For 50 days, I posted 50 videos consecutively a few of the videos started to get popular
I made one talking about how I got into Harvard which started to get a little bit of attention as you can imagine
with you know the clickbait title how I got into Harvard?
For a while and that video is kind of my story how I got into Harvard
So I think that did almost
100,000 views in a month and that was the first real experience for me where it's just like wow
This is that I could really do
I think the way that YouTube connects with academics for me at least and in
moreso with my general life at Harvard
I think in order to actually
really take in a lesson you need to reflect on it because it's very easy at Harvard
to just kind of continue just going through
the motions and just you know going from class to
Midterm to final to class there and so on.
And not really taking a moment to pause and reflect and I think what YouTube allows
me is this ability to reflect this kind of time I that I take out at the same?
What am I really learning here? You know like what are the lessons? How am I changing? How am I growing and
By dedicating that time to it it kind of ties it in together
Well, it lets me look back and kind of see how I've grown and changed over time.